[Musique]
à vrai dire tous les produits de la mer
du retard qu'est ce que c'est que cette
merde
parisé pour le même j'ai connu ça
voilà tu solo bien non c'est une fois
cette zone
ils roulent aujourd'hui mais on verront
pas demain ou après demain en même temps
son riz l'afrique au monde
rungis 4 heures du matin gérard du port
restaurateurs fait ses courses
il se dirige vers le pavillon le plus
animé du marché là on va aller sur le
marché aux volailles la voilà les
gibiers donc
là déjà ça remue aussi
normalement à
gérard à ses habitudes il sera en
priorité chez gino catena un des
meilleurs vendeurs du pavillon bonjour
maison catena vélo dans une pro des
cuisses soit pour du foie gras comme
d'habitude ça s'est fait jeter mi5
coleader web et de regarder quand même
ouais
ça saigne encore c'est tout frais coupés
quoi rien à dire moi je dis bien là
parce que j'ai pas de souci à chercher
moi j'ai pas de temps à perdre
ce que je veux c'est que ce soit bien
donc
après le prix va me le dire mais bon
dino vie cuisse ça vaut combien ce matin
aa
bon
en temps normal je les fais à l'hfr
l'hymne de 3 euros pour 3 euros le kilo
non je pense qu'il va baisser un peu
peut-être pas de 50 centimes parce que
il y a du mal à y arriver aussi lui donc
j'attends un petit peu des gauches et ça
convient vous en faut quatre rencontres
où il demandé trois piscines pour lui
chaque matin des milliers de colis de
volailles de foie gras ou de petits
gibiers donne à ce pavillon un des plus
anciens de registre des allures de new
york en miniature ici entre 4h et 7h du
matin les prix montent et descendent
comme à la bourse
gino catena porte le chapeau des grands
patrons ce matin il est particulièrement
en forme
il a trouvé une astuce pour dynamiser
ses ventes il organisait sur son stand
une dégustation pour ses meilleurs
clients des acheteurs habituellement
précédent porté leurs commandes ont été
invités à découvrir ses nouveaux
produits
[Musique]
les ménagères c'est les gars les anciens
et les plus tueur clients sont conviés à
déguster autour d'un bon verre de
nouvelles variétés de foie gras spécial
noël
c'est de cette façon que les acheteurs
découvrent les nouveaux arrivages au
pavillon de la volaille
il faut dire que gino a une grande
qualité il aime prendre des risques et
renouvelle constamment son offre de
produits frais c'est un joueur l'aïd
année on a au moins tripler quadrupler
les ventes sur un seul produit en
faisant déguster les gens le produit
voulait pas l'acheter ils l'ont goûté
ils ont trouvé ça super il n'y a pas
beaucoup qui le tour ça ici comme on a
un métier où on est opérationnel
immédiatement et comprend tout plein
fouet aussi bien en bien en mal geoff en
arrive à réparer
gino catena est un des plus gros
vendeurs du pavillon de la volaille un
titre qu'ils remettent en jeu chaque
matin car la concurrence n'est qu'à
quelques mètres de son étalage les
autres vendeurs sont à l'affût du
moindre signe de faiblesse de gino mais
je sais pas chacun fait son business et
je n'ai rien acheté des petites
bouteilles de vente
oui pour voir si millions les pros chez
mon voisin parce qu'en fait on est tous
un peu jaloux quand même les uns les
autres et là c'est la jalousie promet de
préserver
en fait gino surveille particulièrement
michel un de ses anciens vendeurs passer
à la concurrence
formé à l'école gino il a bien
l'intention de lui ravir un jour le
titre de roi du foie gras et il a des
arguments pour ses clients amis ont
offert des foies gras depuis longtemps
fait toujours des tarifs est en face
c'est pas moins cher si mais c'est pas
la même qualité
ça c'est des spéciaux j'ai un petit
prince en d'autres produits
pour les fêtes de fin d'année le grand
challenge c'est le foie gras alors gino
observe tout petit coup d'oeil ça donne
quoi
ça donne qui a pas beaucoup de clients
dans le passé puis que
que c'est bien chargé
c'est vrai que c'est pas trop agitée
[Musique]
bien chargé autrement dit les ventes
n'ont pas encore démarré
alors en attendant tout le monde
s'observe gino se trouve derrière nous
ouais si les valets vidéo judo
ado comme moi bien client a récupéré la
houppe restants dont il avait quitté sa
vendeuse
irena monde ya des clients de chez
moi j'en ai récupéré quelques années je
vais pas donner leur nom c'est pas la
joie
tiens regardez dans la maison maintenant
mais attention à trop surveillé le
voisin on oublie quelquefois ses propres
clients et ce matin ça commence mal pour
michel ce client n'est pas content on a
oublié sa commande passée la veille
ses cheveux
il est chez nous et ça c'est fait pour m
pour la paillade
de vrais les meubles pour
ça ne va pas
maïs et dépanner avec un collègue il à
décharger la marchandise chez un autre
collègue qui avait pas tout aujourd'hui
heureusement pour lui donc on a pu
récupérer 80% de la commande c'est quand
même mieux d'aller chercher la
concurrence se fait plus frais quand
même
justement
changez la couleur
[Musique]
j'aime mieux quand la barque était
rentré vers ses couleurs de l'espérance
c'est moins vendeur comme sa rivale
trulli
c'est très grave
ça fait 25 ans cachette dans cette
maison alors oubliez un client comme moi
c'est un peu
c'est un peu dommage quoi
et ça contrarie quoi
à
on les met un petit peu dans le placard
pour on va acheter à la concurrence
pendant un mois
c'est la sanction
et là la différence
la concurrence est là
problème si le suivi derrière quoi il
faut sans arrêt se bat tous les jours et
qu'on se bat la fère semble réglée quand
tout à coup notre client découvre un
défaut sur l'emballage de ses produits
c'est parce que j'ai co
alors il est où le poivre cette fois
rien ne va plus voilà ils m'ont encore
laissé tomber je vais aller en faire
mais gilbert fassent tuer enfin jouer à
côté
donc ils ont changé la barque est tout
simplement séché au point
c'est le même produit dans une autre
pièce il ya tromperie
le pivot jaune et il est où le soleil
enfin c'est le beaujolais pour les
clients petites bouteilles de beaujolais
cadeaux alors qu'ils étaient comme
en face le vin coule à flot et le foie
gras part comme des petits pains gino
c'est que comme au restaurant la
clientèle attire la clientèle et notre
acheteurs mécontents passe à la
concurrence sans état d'âme mais vous
allez voir que pour ce nouveau client
la partie est loin d'être gagnée car
rappelons le à rungis comme en amour
les vendeurs aime les clients fidèles et
ce n'est pas le meilleur moment pour
critiquer la marchandise
mieux
gino a entendu mais il fait la sourde
oreille il n'apprécie pas les gamins
puissent de pintade suprême de matane
[Musique]
nos deux mois des corps mais c'est papa
on approche remonter les cours c'est pas
parce que tu es voisin l'espagne s'est
plus laissée un euro de plus chaque
semaine on sait pas ce que tu achètes
poids chez les bons alors dit long
je vais pas le prendre aujourd'hui quand
même pour la chaîne ne l'achète pas chez
les bons de caisse en france je vais
voir en face à aaa
les joueurs et les autres motions et
c'est le même jeu chaque matin au
pavillon de la volaille
[Musique]
régis un marché gigantesque qui
désormais se visite comme un site
touristique ce secteur pour la vente est
ouvert de 3 heures du matin jusqu'à 9
heures un peu près des caisses qui
marque le début du marché alors à la sur
votre droite
le bâtiment de la triperie dans la
question c'était halloween oui la
question c'était comment ça se passe
tout le monde arrive se met en place à
droite ici les services vétérinaires les
bureaux des services vétérinaires c'est
difficile de répondre aux questions
qu'est-ce qui marque le début que les
produits soient arrivés ce matin madame
dutheuil fait découvrir un jce un groupe
d'agriculteurs en pénétrant dans le
pavillon des produits laitiers
leur surprise est totale
ça c'est du piment pas vous dire ça l'
immense à on a eu des chefs mais il fait
parisé pour le manger comme des salaires
ça veut dire quoi moi je vous ai ménagé
jusqu'à maintenant jeu parisien à dix
oise mais parisienne madame du tout y
est susceptible ou plutôt elle veut
éviter toute polémique sur l'arrivée de
produits étrangers sur le marché de
rungis
regardez les parages de chair en forme
de cloche quand je vous dis car âgées
sont pas des choses qu'on ne voit nulle
part ailleurs
alors elle fait diversion il faut dire
que ces fromages en forme de pâtisserie
n'ont plus rien de traditionnel en forme
de coeur messieurs
messieurs les fromages de chèvre forme
de coeur là l'originalité des volets de
la présentation mais aujourd'hui
reproduit là il a bon il a bon être bon
elle a beau être gustatif tout ce que
vous voulez il faut la présentation est
déterminante
sur certains marchés jacques et
producteur de fromage il va devoir
s'adapter pour vendre son reblochon le
fameux fromage à tartiner est pascal
vient justement de repérer du fromage à
tartiner let mais d'origine étrangère
pendant que certains déguste elle est
allé avertir jacques et alors c'est très
bon mais vous savez maintenant faites
vous les dommages pour ceux qui n'aiment
pas être moi je moi je suis producteur
de reblochon je suis producteur de
reblochon en haute savoie
on a donc du reblochon pour faire la
tartiflette qui est aussi un fromage
d'origine de notre département
aujourd'hui on est copiée par d'autres
marques des produits qui sont de même
taille qu'une robe le ton et qui se
vendent aussi dans nos magasins presque
aussi cher mais le problème c'est là que
les démarches des marchands arrive à
marcher beaucoup plus sur les produits
comme ça chez les produits
niveaux bas d'un dutheuil cherche une
parade ils viennent en concurrence
directe de nos produits de marque cd
copé
enfin je me suis dit lisa de fête
parisienne je vois si vous êtes
d'origine italienne
vous saurez 1
voilà moi ce que j'aime c'est par les
mules de parmesan elle entraîne notre
groupe assez rapidement dans le pavillon
des fruits et légumes au coeur de
l'hiver
c'est ici que l'on trouve des fruits
contre-saison raisin du chili fraises du
sud de l'espagne
tomates ou quelquefois groseilles on est
au mois de décembre
vous avez quand même de la fraise
d'amour alors c'est de la braise sous
serre mais vous avez de la fraise
française en décembre la chorale de
toute l'année les consommateurs prennent
s'ils ont perdu les repères de la
production éthique des produits par
exemple les tournages télé dès
maintenant
le kit mains libres les bonnes séries
jouait maintenant vous en avez toute
l'année les gens mais ça arrive produit
quelle époque on doit le consommer
personne ils ont tous le rythme des
saisons
agissent pour répondre aux besoins de
tous et c'est le marché de paris et de
l'ile-de-france avant et c'est le sais
parce que justement ici on trouve de
tout excès à marcher vraiment que les
acheteurs de province viennent que les
acheteurs de l'étranger sont à thiers le
sujet sensible
madame duteil entraîne son groupe vers
la sortie en évitant cette fois de
passer devant d'autres étalage de fruits
contre saison trop tard pascal bien de
voir cette fois des cerises de noël
avant des produits red de loi alors
après la cerise australie qu'est ce que
vous voyez un bon alors qu un autre
département les producteurs sont en
crise ils ont pas moins dû les tomates
et paix
zen du léger dépassement
si certains agriculteurs partent un peu
découragé pour d'autres cette visite à
provoquer une prise de conscience non
produit donc on reste sur nos fermes
il faudrait que de plus en plus les
agriculteurs ils sortent de leur ferme
pour aller voir en aval qu'est ce qui se
passe comment ça se négocie commence à
ce vent qui les achètent ça ça nous
paraît utile à je suis convaincu de cela
tout à fait donc déjà je vous remercie
de votre intérêt pour agissent
ces visites guidées ont lieu trois à
quatre fois par semaine depuis quelques
mois des tours opérators ont même
inscrit rungis dans leurs circuits
touristiques
pour être bien pour le poisson vont être
d'abord vers 3h 3h30 du matin
[Musique]
c'est pas prendre ça thierry
le lendemain matin pendant que la france
d'or le plus grand marché du monde de
produits frais s'éveille rungis
accueille chaque jour plus de 26000
véhicules dont 3000 gros porteurs des
milliers de tonnes de viande de fruits
et légumes de produits laitiers et de
poissons sont acheminés sur cette zone
de 232 hectares à une heure du matin
ce pavillon est déjà en activité c'est
le pavillon à 4 celui de la marée dans
les coulisses on s'active poissons
coquillages et crustacés pêchés dans
toutes les mers et océans du monde sont
acheminés le plus vite possible sur les
carreaux du dernier né des pavillons de
rungis surnommé la cathédrale des mères
le pavillon de la marée va ouvrir ses
portes dans 10 minutes chaque matin
surtout en période de fin d'année
monsieur manzetti livre fièrement le
même combat
c'est tous les jours la guerre on est
dans la gamme nage pour que sa soirée
c'est pas l'heure
les appliques périssables jours
c'est arrivé ça repart pratiquement
c'est ça qui est très dur pour passer
pour les amener les marchandises
viens de normandie revient dans
l'attenté qu'elle vienne du nord ça
vient de la méditerranée donc c'est à
peine arrivé on a un laps de temps qui
est très très court
c'est ça notre soutien j'arrive tout ça
ça c'est l'élan but de californie
en de la marée on pourrait dire tous les
produits de la mer sur votre table ouais
langue russe de californie elles
arrivent elles sont vivantes sont passés
par la belgique si on reste encore sur
un marché exceptionnel
les cigales se souvient des côtes ouest
de l'afrique
la nature est belle en france surtout la
nature vivante la ville
c'est sur ce très beau du temps et tu
vois pense à côte à côte partout
[Musique]
oh
sous le pavillon de la marée l'offre est
exceptionnel tourteau de nouvelle
calédonie sardines d'afrique du sud
langoustes du canada daurade de
méditerranée presque tous les produits
de la mer sont commercialisés mais comme
à la bourse
l'accès à cette vitrine se fait à une
heure très précise et fournira deux
heures selon plein énorme et c'est vous
n'avez pas le droit d'être là
pour revenir à 2 heures on n'a pas le
droit vous n'avez pas le droit d'être
sur le marché voilà deux heures le
rideau va bientôt se lever pour des
centaines de grossistes et de petits
commerçants
deux heures c'est aussi l'heure à
laquelle gérard vient faire ses courses
à la marée
bien qu'on se croise on voit d'abord à
vers 3h et 3h30 du matin minimum après
c'est fini les meilleurs morceaux sont
ce qui est le mieux est partie déjà pour
faire des affaires à rungis il faut être
à l'heure et dès l'ouverture
les acheteurs se précipitent sur les
carreaux
cela fait près de vingt ans que gérard
du port se rend à rungis plusieurs fois
par semaine dès son arrivée il juge en
un seul coup d'oeil la qualité des
arrivages
c'est pas mal ça va dans les rouges et
sont pas mal mais on va sûrement trouver
mieux ailleurs on va trouver mieux en
france qu'au mieux aller vers un ton
gérard évalue en priorité le cours du
marché
pour cela il a son indique monsieur
pécuniaire la plus ancienne entreprise
de la mare et messieurs c'est beau c'est
beau et la marchandise ce matin qu'est
ce qu'il ya de mieux au saumon juin
et ça ça vaut combien ça au revoir
on va voir si ces derniers prix ça
un peu juste
tap les u 10 centimes monsieur gougnan
c'est énorme 30 centimes peut-être on
commence pas dans la même cour
bien sûr voulait pas seulement fait des
savanes ce matin 120 meilleurs n'ont pas
encore la mer dans le second dans les
dom ce matin il y jette mon y en a deux
la bretonne comme d'habitude igm inc
ab pour ce métier toujours hier j'ai
jamais la chance ou pas la chance
non c'est beau même creux comme ça c'est
bon
et là qu'il est membre
gérard est exigeant il goûte les
produits un privilège que l'on accorde
qu vieux clients la fraîcheur est un
critère comme ces saint-jacques encore
vivante fait le pouce
1 le bronze cette extension
non c'est pas vrai c'est pas mal je vais
faire quand même un petit tour j'allais
voir ce lien
mais avant d'acheter gérard va jeter un
coup d'oeil chez les concurrents ici
pour faire baisser les prix
les acheteurs ont une astuce vieille
comme le monde je me suis un an j'étais
gamin j'ai commencé à vendre mon père il
m'a tout de suite la prison m'a dit
quand tu veux acheter quelque chose ne
regarde jamais ce que tu veux acheter
regarde toujours à côté
déjà c'est une chose même quand ils
regardent pas quelque chose qui va
acheter qu'on s'y intéresse
et lui il va pas plonger
systématiquement sur la tête qui
l'intéressent
il va d'abord faire un petit tour voilà
et puis après il revient doucement sur
la ville qui veulent l'intéressé c'est
sûr monde arabe 4 euros 50 le kilo de
saumon sauvage sans négocier gérard
obtient 4 euros 30 le prix de la
fidélité qui m'ont aimée 3 way froid
si tu arrives en tant que touriste qui
tu viens là par hasard c'est sûr que les
prix augmentent mais bon ils savent que
de toute manière que s'ils roulent
aujourd'hui mais en verrons pas demain
ou après demain
donc moi j'ai des factures je sais prix
qu'il a vendu la semaine dernière
et si cette semaine il me facture trop
fort mais bon là je sais que de manière
ça vaut 4 30 langues lui gagné 20
centimes d'euro saumon décosse gambas de
madagascar coquilles saint-jacques
huîtres d'oléron
gérard a fait le plein il a économisé ce
matin 70 euros sur les cours du jour
grâce à sa fidélité chaque année
l'économie de 3 à 4000 euros
dès 5h ce quartier de rungis est
consacrée aux produits carnés dans ce
pavillon une vingtaine de grossistes se
partagent le marché de la viande
ici les bouchers traditionnels portant
leurs carcasses à l'épaule se font rares
ils ont cédé leur place à des
manutentionnaires
pas de temps mort dans les coulisses de
la viande
[Musique]
il y a quelques années chaque bouche
était encore capable de découper
n'importe quelle partie d'une carcasse
aujourd'hui le travail s'est spécialisée
pour aller plus vite tout est organisé à
la chaîne le pavillon de la viande
numéro un est ultra-moderne espace
éclairage propreté la viande est exposée
comme dans les vitrines d'une galerie
marchande
ici la viande d'origine française se
fait de plus en plus rare désormais à
rungis
elle arrive en majorité des pays de
l'est
l'avenir est à son arrivée en france
bientôt il y aura plus de loges verra
plus rien tout se perd en france
la viande des pays de l'est une viande
moins cher mais pas tout à fait au goût
de gérard notre restaurateur d'avion des
pays de l'est c'est pas
palacios eux
qualité
pas nourri camani
ne pas dire que
fraîcheur n'est pas la même non plus
quand on prend de la viande française
s'appelle étrangères
transpire ça colle c'est
dans le pavillon de la viande
nous sommes loin des forts en gueule des
halles de paris ou de la villette
les acheteurs artisans bouchers sont de
moins en moins nombreux ils sont
remplacés par des acheteurs spécialisés
qui négocient en grande quantité pour
les supérettes et les supermarchés
pendant l'hiver une viande plus rustique
mais bien français cette fois fait son
apparition à rungis le gibier sauvage ce
matin cet atelier sert de zone de
transit à des sangliers abattus par des
chasseurs d'île de france
le sanglier par jour en moyenne
à dépenser des chasseurs sont bons
une centaine
[Musique]
oui
pourquoi ce local est sous haute
surveillance cette gibier donc ces
sauvages
ça veut dire que
à voir que facilement des maladies que
les deux matches c'est qu'on fait
les jours qu'est ce qui peut arriver
or le sanglier la tribune
tient son billet qu'à l'attelé qui doit
obligatoirement
poubelle cette viande et donc contrôler
tous les matins par les services
vétérinaires de rungis le parasite si le
tri qui n'est là spinali ce donc qui lui
si jamais une personne lingère peut être
sujette à plusieurs symptômes c'est
super dangereux pour la santé publique
mais ça arrive jamais
c'est un quartier très rare parce qu'ils
ont fait
la science est arrivé à prévenir des
maladies mais le risque zéro n'existe
pas donc autant inspecté betfair bête
tous ces gibiers ne seront mises à la
vente qu'après un examen minutieux opéré
par les inspecteurs vétérinaires à
rungis
ils sont une vingtaine j'aurais nuits à
traquer la moindre anomalie sanitaires
ce matin le commando vétérinaire doit
inspecter plus d'une soixantaine de
sangliers les viscères et organes vitaux
sont extraits pour servir d'échantillons
analyse des extraits de fois les langues
et les reins sont envoyés au laboratoire
vétérinaire national de rungis une bonne
tour tikal une bonne médullaire et rien
sur mon
[Musique]
où un barrage non j'suis apparaît là
classe
en fait nous avons une carcasse
qui pourrait faire l'objet de saisies
par ce pour sourire
c'est pas propre thierry tu peux la
mettre de côté cette bête là
elle n'ira pas loin
le sanglier suspect est immédiatement
mise en quarantaine
il est isolé des autres sangliers pour
éviter toute contamination possible
le laboratoire rendra son verdict dans
quelques heures
merci il faut aller vite on travaille en
flux tendu entre
régis un énorme marché que se disputent
1400 entreprises une gigantesque ruche
où se croisent chaque jour plus de 20000
négociant pour qui le transport des
produits frais est soumis à des règles
d'hygiène très strictes mais à régis
difficile de tout contrôler à l'entrée
comme à la sortie
alors ce matin d'autres vétérinaires se
sont associés avec le service des
douanes pour monter une opération
coup-de-poing que tous les véhicules
suspects sont systématiquement inspectés
en priorité les inspecteurs vétérinaires
vérifie la disposition des marchandises
les produits frais doivent
impérativement ne pas se toucher une
mesure obligatoire pour éviter une
prolifération des bactéries en vrac
c'est parce que j'avais pas trop de
place pour ça il faut bien séparer à
tout niveau de vue nue les cartons
papiers de contact avec l'avion avec la
chine apporte
puis c'est le test de la température il
est déterminant 1° de trop et c'est
l'amande synchronisme
ce matin tout va bien pour ce petit
artisan mais le chauffeur un peu inquiet
referme tout de même rapidement les
portes de son fourgon projets pv
ah bon un camion pourri ça j'en ai déjà
vu les mecs ça tombe en ruine les frigos
qui fonctionne pas c'est une catastrophe
ce qu'ils ont raison je pense qu'il faut
un peu du gel corps
il est 7 heures du matin de nombreux
véhicules quittent la zone rapidement
pour éviter les embouteillages du
périphérique à cet or si les voitures de
tourisme sont suspectes les douanes
viennent d'arrêter ce véhicule
transportant des quartiers de viande à
même le corps
votre argent dit regardez vous plongez
les cartels avec avec de la viande
quelle que soit la quantité vous n'avez
pas le droit d'utiliser un véhicule
particulier pour transporter
la marchandise
même pas une fourgonnette rien je parle
de vie des véhicules particuliers
et la sanction est immédiate ce boucher
peu scrupuleux des règles d'hygiène
vient de perdre sa matinée passée à
rungis
la viande
cette fois les services n'ont pas besoin
d'inspecter le verdict est sans appel et
à bâtir
je veux que tu saches matière à
disserter
ce véhicule ne quittera pas rungis avec
sa marchandise nous allons lui faire
ramener sa marchandise
où il a acheté chez son fournisseur et
il viendra rechercher sa marchandise
dans un véhicule conforme
ce grossiste vient de perdre une journée
de travail et ce matin il ne sera pas le
seul
jeunesse marchandises que je repère mais
je reviens pas non je pars faire
les payer 7 euros d'entrée 10 euros avec
le camion un beau temps à les détruire
en deux heures une dizaine de véhicules
comme celui-ci rebrousseront chemin
il est 7 heures du matin c'est la course
contre la montre les derniers extraits
d'abba de sangliers sont acheminés au
laboratoire national vétérinaire de
rungis pour gagner du temps dans l'
expertise des produits frais ce
laboratoire a été installé à quelques
centaines de mètres des pavillons de
rungis très bien aussi
merci la présence de tri keane dans des
sangliers est extrêmement rare
trois cas en quinze ans il faut faire
vite les analyses doivent être délivrés
avant midi les opérateurs attendent nos
résultats pour pouvoir commercialiser
les gibiers qui sont consignés par les
services vétérinaires et à quelle heure
vous allez pouvoir donner ses résultats
vers 11h30 12h les travaillant
toute envie en permanence
et pas question de laisser la moindre
place au hasard pour reproduire les
conditions de la digestion normale d'un
consommateur
les extraits sont d'abord h et avant
d'être dissous par des acides
puis ils sont centrifugé
ces opérations dureront près de quatre
heures le verdict n'aura lieu que sous
le rétroprojecteur de ce microscope
[Musique]
ce matin le hasard se manifeste de la
façon la plus inquiétante
deux sangliers suspects sont infestés de
tri keane c'est bien ça en france est
rarissime c'est de l'ordre une fois tous
les dix ans elle avoue on étende est
tombé dessus
c'est une chanson peut dire mais enfin
c'est plutôt un coup de malchance ces
rapports entre le laboratoire averti
immédiatement les inspecteurs
vétérinaires
allô bonjour c'est alain guignard le
directeur du laboratoire national des
vétérinaires de rungis sur le lot de son
billet qu'on a reçue ce matin
eh bien vous n'allez pas en croire vos
oreilles nous avons trouvé des tris
chine
d'ailleurs il s'en va avec
c'est de la rue
ces deux sangliers ont été diagnostiqués
positifs à la
hattrick et donc ils vont aller
directement la destruction
retour dans le dernier pavillon flambant
neuf de rungis
la marée 215 mètres de long que se
partagent 25 grandes maisons ici chaque
carreau à son vendeur le plus ancien
travail chez clément gilles thomas
l'espagnol c'est le vendeur le plus
courtisé de la marée salut mon ami comme
java c est un ami d'être un temps là on
allait ensemble à l'école wsj vélo n'est
pas répéter les uns de ses vignes à ce
jeu les clients que j'ai connu de toute
ma vie et j'ai suivi toute ma vie à
toute la famille ça c'est des durs sas
et des dégâts qu'il cause la retraite
des cas
[Musique]
mais au delà de l'amitié il y a les
affaires et de ce côté là thomas a son
caractère
des problèmes d'attention josé maria
riva oui moi aussi on il a toujours
paralysé toute façon même moi c'est la
mort en guyane agen des grillades
d'alcool et si le carnet de commandes de
thomas est toujours plein c'est parce
qu'il n'a qu'une parole
wendel salon man city se réunir très
riche et chetumal clients c'est quoi
être nette baisse et ne s'est pas tu
rentres clients dit
et voilà ça c'est beau ça c'est pas beau
ça fout les frire ou des machines
loisirs ou acheter parce que après
demain c'est plus cher
non mes clients tir de fusée
je sache si tu viens à 4,5 grâce à votre
5,5 c'est pas cher vont faire la quête
en jambes du mali tu me dis c'est pas
cher que l'ovale
la caisse comment on définit c'est un
bon client
c'est tout j'ai beaucoup en confiance un
client fidèle 7 à l'époque des halles de
paris il ya 42 ans que thomas a conquis
ses premiers clients
mais ce matin rien ne va plus son patron
lui a pris une mauvaise nouvelle
il va devoir prendre définitivement sa
retraite dans un mois et quitter le
navire de la marée pour rejoindre sa
castille natale la nouvelle a déjà fait
le tour du pavillon la concurrence en
frottent les mains
françois boucher mon avis
qui va la remplacer
traitement pour l'instant je sais pas je
serais à la place de clément en chine je
peux rentrer à faire du souci
justement le départ de thomas inquiète
monsieur clément le patron de la maison
gym l'homme à la casquette écossaise
derrière son sourire se cache une petite
inquiétude
ça envoie ça
pour moi oui
travaillent la nuit c'est pas ça
dangereux dans les mythes ou
financièrement parlant quand la bonheur
des gens d'ici ont 100 % à leur métier
c'est la faute de carre
c'est lui
des sommes d'argent qui disparaissent
vautours un domaine mais thomas a tout
prévu
avant son départ il a choisi son
remplaçant le jeune boris 22 ans c'est
lui qui va prendre la relève des lieux
clients de thomas mais avant cela il
devra d'abord se faire respecter par
l'équipe
je pense qu'on dort comme un bon rythme
non ça c'est trop beau
fort bien
peut-être casting de 30 ans
face au bruit comme et des patates des
boîtes
et surtout gagner la confiance des vieux
clients de thomas
peut-être quatre ans
mais sans cela
[Musique]
fabien séquences et des poissons
il
la pièce
je les fais en pièce tu veux
je vais m'ennuyer
et là c'est bien pendant ce temps thomas
veille sur lui
la barbade
espérant que le type de la main fera son
affaire sur place
je dois du tampon gamins se ses cours
c'est très court
ses coûts
pour faire vite pourtant validé
on va avoir le flair du marché cerveau
cher ça vaut pas cher
si ça peut
et ce afin qu'elle n'a pas de sens quand
il à maputo pour remonter le mans de
flamber quant aux blessés pour des c
ce soir dans ce marché
comment ça va
ça fait de vagues alors chaque fois
qu'un gros clients arrivent thomas
annonce son départ à la retraite et en
profite pour placer le petit chien
s'appelle volistes un numéro évoluent là
cela tu l'appelles tout fait comme moi
est aboli ce sera aux commandes là pour
dire
à vomir relation client des quarante ans
les vendredis il fait une grosse colère
donc il va rester fidèle à gbagbo dit
alors ces clients là il nous fait
aujourd'hui 100 kg viennois de 60 kg de
ta vidéo tranquille ollier chose et puis
dès que les échos la vie de passer à un
autre vendeur derrière coma il a fait
quand même le relationnel et
[Musique]
elle m'a présenté donc s'accroissent
entre collègues oui c'est pas toujours
facile mais
ça très collé ce qui va apprendre sur le
tas aussi fait 180
[Musique]
devant la clientèle est face à son
équipe
boris cache son angoisse il va devoir
s'imposer et le verdict ce sera chaque
matin ce carnet qu'il devra remplir
comme thomas et peut-être même plus
[Musique]
je sais que ça va être difficile agit
pas que ça va être facile hein
je sais que ça va être des nuits où je
vais pas dormir beaucoup
[Musique]
jamais et dans la cathédrale des mères
les miracles n'existent pas boris futurs
vendeurs en chef va devoir très
rapidement prendre la relève ou s'en
aller
un lieu assez ingrat mérité de faire du
melon pour noël alors ils avaient vingt
et quelques colis ont valu en maître 30
[Musique]
m
oh
4h30 le locataire du dernier étage d'un
immeuble parisien se prépare à rejoindre
son lieu de travail
natacha et irlandaises elle a quitté
dublin il ya cinq ans pour venir
s'installer dans le 14e arrondissement
de paris un choix stratégique car elle
peut se rendre deux fois par semaine à
rungis en moins de 15 minutes
natacha est une pionnière dans son
domaine elle exerce un tout nouveau
métier à rungis
je suis acheteuses sur le marché
international j'exporte les produits au
chef cuisinier d'irlande
alors je dois commencer très tôt pour
être sûr d'acheter les meilleurs
produits qui sont disponibles le matin à
rungis
ce n'est pas un peu dur pour une femme
de travailler sur un gif et je fais ça
deux fois par semaine et c'est vraiment
excitant de travailler à rungis
c'est une passion j'adore découvrir de
nouveaux produits qui arrivent sur le
marché
j'ai une chance incroyable de faire ce
métier
vraiment
le d'un million 600 mille tonnes de
produits frais transitent chaque année
sur cette zone unique au monde
c'est dans cette corne d'abondance que
natacha traque de nouveaux produits pour
ses prestigieux clients
ce matin elle se rend en priorité au
pavillon de la volaille un des plus
grands chefs cuisiniers de dublin lui a
demandé pour les fêtes de fin d'année de
trouver les meilleurs foie gras frais de
rungis et pour cela elle a l'oeil expert
d'ailleurs ici on la surnomme les yeux
de rungis
natacha on dit que vous avez les yeux de
rungis pourquoi sûrement parce que
j'examine soigneusement la qualité des
produits que j'achète pour les grands
chefs parce que je dois m'assurer qu'ils
sont parfaites mais pour natacha la
liste est longue
elle doit également déniché en urgence
une volaille d'une variété particulière
pour cela elle a aussi son expert gino
catena encore lui
bien sûr ce nouveau produit
c'est le
jeanine du domaine désolé mais pas lui
j'ai besoin
oui c'est
un grand chef de dublin vient d'inscrire
sur son menu de noël la fameuse géline
de touraine on me demande un produit je
dois à le trouver
si je ne trouve pas un produit c'est
parce qu'il ya une vraie raison d'un
problème aux abattoirs ou autre chose
mais il y a une vraie raison
stocker ses parents qu'à la tête
et le prix de chine de torrente 06 euros
veut faire quelque chose ah bah non non
non non c'est un produit de qualité
volume de gauche on y verra quand way
d'accord voilà vos actions
il ya des produits ce que tu ne te sera
remplacée par d'autres car leurs noms
sont déjà sur le menu donc je dois
absolument les trouver natacha veut
exporter un autre produit totalement
inconnu des irlandais le saut il s en
plus c'est difficile à trouver sa peau
du poulet qui se situe au niveau de la
carcasse oui juste au dessus de la
cuisse au niveau des carcasses et benoît
z comme ça on s'est très tendre très
mauvais et pour moi dans cinq ans
bonjour j'ai mettre sa demande et
servait buckingham palace
ah oui bon de queen ah la la
le vendeur en profite pour lui présenter
un autre produit les crêtes de coq
ça veut dire quoi en français si les
crêtes et reste et le français il mange
sa cuisine y est le fait griller
légèrement pour enlever la petite faute
qui est dessus et ensuite le ser ait une
bonne sauce se relever c'est un plat
très fort et on reste il est 6 heures
cette fois natacha a rendez vous au
pavillon des fruits et légumes
il en existe neuf comme celui ci a
rungis partagé par près de 180
grossistes
sous ce seul pavillon 5000 cageots
seront échangés dans la matinée
pour natacha ce coin de rungis est un
paradis c'est sans odeur de croix
[Musique]
c'est pavillons sont de véritable
caverne d'ali baba où natacha bien
dénicher chaque jour de nouveaux trésors
comme ces légumes anciens
on appelle cela des légumes oubliés c56
fisac scorsonère
le site ancêtre de la carotte et ça
c'est la racine de persil on sentait un
peu dans les couscous ou dans l'est
c'est très spécial
racine je vais is wrong kg ça revient
beaucoup à la mode
le topinambour en france ça reste un
synonyme de
r parce qu'on mange s à la place des
pommes de terre et donc ça s'appelait
avant la pomme de terre du pauvre
maintenant c'est devenu beaucoup plus
cher que la scène
certains grands chefs d'irlande
particulièrement de dublin courtisent
natacha pour ce faire acheminer des
produits rares qui feront la différence
sur leur nouveau menu en quelques années
les fameux yeux de natacha ont lancé de
nouvelles modes culinaires
c'est mon travail si je découvre un
nouveau produit qui arrive sur le marché
mon boulot c'est d'en parler au grand
chef mes clients chasse et après cela je
travaille avec le producteur qui
m'envoient son produit directement de la
ferme
mais je suis en fait la personne qui
fait le lien entre le producteur et le
chef dax je fais connaître le projet
mais qui leur permet de créer de
nouveaux place en fait ils ont besoin de
la matière nouvelle et les chefs qui
sont des artistes peuvent grâce à cela
crée de nouvelles recettes
on peut dire que c'est comme dans la
mode depuis quelques années régis au
coeur de l'hiver vit au rythme des
quatre saisons
on appelle cela la contre saison un
phénomène qui s'est développé avec
l'arrivée des premiers melon de noël
[Musique]
ce
il y a plus de 20 ans claude boyer un
producteur de melons du sud-ouest de la
france à l'idée géniale de planter
quelques graines sur les terre
extrêmement fertile de la guadeloupe des
terres loin de régis et sous un climat
capricieux
chaque année la récolte est un véritable
challenge
i la plupart terrés et on voit que la
route est mouillée mais partout là et on
s'approche du site et
c'est chasser chagrine en quoi mais
parce que c'est pas les conditions
idéales en avant ses niveaux longtemps
il a plu
[Musique]
il faut dire qu'on sent juste de la
saison des pluies est que ces ingrats
mérite de faire du mot l'homme pour noël
dans un tigre c'est vraiment pas facile
c'est sur ses terres qu'en 1984 le père
de joël boyer produite une dizaine de
kilos de melon à l'époque on le prend
pour un fou
depuis le terroir des antilles
françaises exportent chaque année plus
de 5000 tonnes de melons vers la
métropole
quand tout va bien ce matin les terres
sont inondées
que la merde a fait le maire d'aggloméré
depuis quelques jours la production est
compromise par la météo
le melon aim l'eau mais pas trop une
fois la graine semée un melon sous le
soleil de guadeloupe arrive à maturité
en moins de trois mois
mais produire ici en grande quantité et
chaque année un véritable pari quelques
millimètres d'eau en trop et c'est la
catastrophe
cette nuit les pluies tropicales en
noyer les cultures de melon joël est
très inquiet mais il garde son calme
si on les laisse apprécier père du fils
de m il faut bien et ramassé juste juste
juste les jours
voir la différence il est parti si on le
laisse
mais il va faire comme à cela que je
tienne à l'e mail la nuit il va éclater
et ses melons perdu dans tout ça c'est
un challenge en fait ils doivent
surveiller de très près que les melons
soit pas trop oubliée alors combien l'a
pas beaucoup en ce moment que c'est
juste le début de la maturité
là ils cherchent pas suffisamment voilà
le travail
voilà celui-là est mort on l'a trop
journaux déjà famille à rungis les
grossistes attendent avec impatience
l'arrivée prochaine des premiers melon
de noël
ces melons ne supporteront pas de
nouvelles pluies ils doivent
impérativement être cueillies sous 48
heures a priori la météo relance le
retour des alizés dans l'hérault le sent
le vent commence à souffler et les
alizés vont assécher la masse nuageuse
vont nettoyer le ciel
et là on devrait partir à b aller s'il a
vraiment il se met à faire ball a
aujourd'hui le vent ne vient souffler
domaine mais ça devrait dans les deux
jours qui suivent la sortir juste juste
juste
il
mais dans les caraïbes
tout peut basculer en un instant des
pluies diluviennes risque d'anéantir en
quelques minutes le travail de trois
mois de culture
heureusement joël boyer est optimiste
comme son père il faut de l'eau toujours
au melon mais juste ce qu'il faut hélas
quand on voit tous ces nuages sont au
dessus de nous là ça vous pose pas un
petit problème petit nuage petit nuage
ça passe plus elle va le voilà
malheureusement la récolte est une fois
de plus compromise
mais joël devant la caméra reste
toujours optimiste sérieuse de manière
ainsi soit il
c'est génial
une petite pluie mais une de trop
d'autres melon venant d'espagne ou du
sénégal peuvent arriver les premiers sur
rungis
la cueillette ne peut être interrompu
les guadeloupéens sont conscients de
cette concurrence
il
[Musique]
quelques minutes plus tard les alizés se
lève et bâle et enfin les nuages
le melon de guadeloupe a encore toutes
ses chances d'arriver à temps à rungis
alors la cadence s'accélère et là aussi
c'est la course contre la montre car ici
on est fier de cette production
c'est un peu de l'âme de la guadeloupe
c'est un peu des hommes et des femmes de
la guadeloupe le soleil la terre de la
moto qui nous qui nous représente et qui
fait notre fierté
ailleurs dans le monde
[Musique]
quelques heures plus tard les premiers
melon traverse le tarmac de l'aéroport
de pointe-à-pitre avant d'embarquer dans
la soute à bagages d'un vol régulier
pour orly
joël voyait surveille le chargement du
coin de l'oeil mais surtout les
touristes qui prennent le même vol ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux chaque
année à rejoindre la métropole pour les
vacances de noël
un constat qui ne l'arrangent pas
vraiment on pouvait charger
régulièrement nous on est plus de melons
les passagers il ya statistiquement
grandi en taille et donc un poids ces
dix dernières années
aujourd'hui on est limité a dit on tout
va bien les melons de guadeloupe seront
dans quelques heures les premiers sur le
marché de rungis à 8h40 sur le sol
métropolitain est dans le viseur 40e
dans la tête de régis aux entrepôts
dégroupage et dans 12h40 sur la table
des consommateurs dans paris ville
23 décembre 3 heures du matin mission
accomplie les neuf tonnes de melons de
la famille boyer ont rejoint régissent
le ventre de la france ils seront tous
vendus en quelques heures et quelques
tonnes repartiront le jour même aux
quatre coins de l'europe
[Musique]
une nouvelle journée commence dans le
pavillon de la volaille à rungis
c'est le dernier jour de marché avant
noël
c'est parti le père noël à tous ces bras
cassés saison 6
ça va papa noël c'est quoi c'est encore
c'est un bon dentiste pour les picoler
ça va mieux qu'hier le manche est bien
meilleur et pas dix meilleurs
on commence à voir le bout du bout du
tunnel donc ça va ça se prolonge pas
combat mon rang est toujours là moi papa
noël
elle n'aime pas son dû faire mouche
[Musique]
ce matin le pavillon est un peu désert
avant de livrer la dernière bataille de
noël la plupart des vendeurs ont du mal
à décoller du saint-hubert le
saint-hubert le seul café de rungis
implanté au centre d'un pavillon
[Musique]
ici au son de l'accordéon les aristos de
la volaille invitent leurs meilleurs
clients à boire le champagne
et pour ne pas déroger à la règle le
patron est un auvergnat
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la tenue de
rigueur pour les serveurs c'est celle du
bunia
en moins de trois heures ils serviront
près de 2500 café pour les travailleurs
et les personnalités du showbiz comme ce
matin jean pierre cassel
[Musique]
alors mes jeux jamais m'en sortir
pendant ce temps gino lui est déjà sur
le pied de guerre
je me ferais habituel 1,7 50,7
6 90 c'est les années 60 900 me
rappeliez chausseur en période de noël
certaines sociétés pont jusqu'à 70 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
les manchons de canard monsieur gérard
est parti c'est tout découpe de canard
tu avais pris goût puis tu as perdu tu
es pas amoureuse mais produit doit les
cuisses de poulet oui ferme hier pour
faire meilleure fermière des classes et
un toit fermé pour ton cher vous fermez
pas cher aujourd'hui
gino joue son va tout il doit liquider
70 tonnes de marchandises et de nouveaux
arrivages avant la clôture du marché à
rungis
on appelle cela une opération mains
propres tous les stocks doivent trouver
acquéreur la chasse est ouverte
ce sont des petits canetons croisé bon
aujourd'hui ce produit là bas il
faudrait que ça parte parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'arrivage derrière les fausses
places et une rotation de stack
évidemment comme tout le temps ça c'est
l'objectif aujourd'hui
objectif se vend du foie gras de canard
les produits très chers c'est des
produits attention et
c'est pas toujours acquis parce que
évidemment quand quand ça coûterait cher
plus pour des coûts de cher et plus on
perd aussi on peut perdre en conséquence
ah bah faut frapper tout ce qui bouge
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça alors de
la gêne ou repère son premier client
démonstration tu veux du foie gras
déveiner du foie gras d'oie tant fait
pour n'importe quelle génération
canetons devant les thèmes qui gagnent
nombreuses et là ça vaut 4 60 de deux
euros pour deux colis 1,2 euro
mais ce lycée prochaine avec non
[Musique]
tiens devant la semaine pile si tu veux
un peu plus frais le côté c'est pareil
je te mettrai des plus forts même prix
c'est parti à bondues merci monsieur les
marchandises bien acheté c'était
marchandises bien vendu est une
marchandise me lâcher c'est une
marchandise dont le put alors à partir
de là je pense qu'on peut développer et
imagine reste en romandie bas il suffit
de se battre sur les produits les
affinités que les fournisseurs la
clientèle les volumes et puis surtout le
alagna qui ont la gnac n'y a pas de gnac
n'a pas de bon sens non non non savoir
d'or comme si la niaque mais aussi le
bagout et dans toutes les langues à
domicile 4 5 et non pas uniquement que
le chinois l'arabe
[Musique]
janex chic de la ged et qu'elle serait
là allez c'est bon
nasrallah c'est bon j'ai pas non la
bombe at war bay c'est fini shaw can
ouais espace espace les foules une
palette de philippe boulet je vais
dégager sata leur royal ait yalla
chocolat mais ce matin après une heure
et demie de vente les stocks de gino ont
du mal à décoller les volailles ne
trouve pas acquéreur
les plus gros clients les asiatiques
sont absents gino a une explication la
diffusion d'un reportage sur l'hygiène
de certains restaurants chinois pour
passer à la télévision automatiques ont
eu un gros un gros problème parce qu'ils
distribuent leur contenu du fait qu'elle
aurait perdu confiance allaient manger
de restaurants chinois et on reçoit
aujourd'hui nous on retour en
marchandises sur le carreau on voit en
retour au niveau des règlements du tout
traîne ça traîne la patte en longueur
est temps que la machine se remette en
place les chinois c'est quand même un
marché prend il un gros marché asiatique
est très bon
alors quand zizou en reperd 1 il ne le
lâche plus l'empathie son regard et
syndicats n'ont pas eu beaucoup de chocs
par la manche il faut les attraper les
clients surtout il est bon mais pour
échapper janati solo bien non
faux c'est le moment où l'on attendait
tiens c'est reparti pour un tour
demain coup deux mois la wii
514 ou premier coup
non non non attendez quand tu me le
faisaient par son colis qui me donnait
chez des moines à la nature de nos coûts
nous aujourd'hui vous social à paris non
non non non non non de mois coûte voilà
au tiare galva c'est les bottes de
quatre kilos là depuis madrid
oui depuis les centres sociaux deux
piles de canards jeux nous vient de
vendre en quelques secondes
70 kg de cuisses de poulet si vous savez
les cuisses blanc là bas
c'est vrai canard celle-ci par 2 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 28 30 ans fait
aussi ou arriver à discuter le but il
est comme ça va on a besoin de dégager
des lots c'est d'en mettre un peu plus
alors ils avaient vingt et quelques
colis ont valu à m contre gicquel à 30
mais on en rajoutera c'est pas grave on
à vu d'oeil sont pas à la hauteur des
girondins veut plus
d'accord c'est fini a pu gonfler
légèrement les commandes un moyen
efficace pour liquider les stocks
il est 20h45 cette fois gino un sérieux
problème
ces fournisseurs lui ont expédié
beaucoup plus de marchands disent que
prévu il va devoir brader les prix et
demandé à ses meilleurs clients de faire
un effort supplémentaire
j'avais grosso modo 30 tonnes de
resserre on a vendu 100 palettes ont
fait une rotation de sens là on
s'appelle sa patte il se fait il qu'il a
ce matin les dés ont des gueules de
marchandises qui dégueule l'un des
fournisseurs qui m'ont mis la
marchandise à vendre du mieux qu'on peut
qui n'étaient pas prévus qui en plus de
ce que j'ai habituellement
donc il faut trouver un deuxième
clientèle faut trouver des gars à gros
volume pour dégager pour les pour aller
plus loin a rungis
tous les produits sont frais ils doivent
être écoulé le plus rapidement possible
à n'importe quel prix cette deuxième
clientèle que gino attend à un nom les
requins ils rôdent vers la fin du marché
et attendre le bon moment pour faire des
affaires mais gino connaît bien le
scénario des dents de la mer
gino c'est un des derniers qui remballe
pascal tour des gars comme cela reste
entre l'appel des requins de conte de
fées qui viennent pour les
pour la fin de marché pour les invendus
oui à tanger avec tout ce qui est en
fait remis à des actes de nom de
consommation et plus la date de
conservation se rapproche à la finale
plus le gars un article qui coûte 6
euros va finir par payer pour un euro
sinon c'est le vétérinaire qui le prend
mais très nerveux l'iran saisies et les
créditeurs
il a guidé mon plan
enfin là vous avez affaire un monsieur
là
c'est très bien manoeuvré ses clients
chacune à faire chez nous vient de
mettre la main sur un de ces requins un
pigeon rôti fera non agréé doit attendre
les malgré ces bons gènes de ton pays
on sait qu est ce que tu ne vas pas
ce client est le championnat par
palettes dans ce haut lieu d'avoir un
colis de colis puis c'est 50 cents colis
que les pc que des marchés à nogent le
rotrou
il paye pas de mine mais ça fort
les voir aller voir les palettes t bonds
des galeries même des données non non ça
lui prenait 3 1
revin ben non je sais pas dire
la commune qu'al hilal et fracas vaincu
les noms
aujourd'hui plus de doute on est présent
règlement
maj il a précicé les voiliers gillot
comment tu le prends un prix ou trois
fois pendant l prix il va casser le prix
en jeu il va il va emmener tout il va le
faire
tu vas le faire on va revenir avec va
les marquer vous avez entendu le prix
qu'il a fait d'ailleurs encore une bonne
pièce est et qui va lui faire
je devrais y voir mais ça parte au delà
ce matin par tonne et voyez visuellement
beau salon handica chez kelkoo
fait que des marchés que des marchés
alors que sur l'autre grâce de canard et
non non c'est bon
bon courage pour avouer ma loge me faire
ma propre j'en ai chargé de palettes
ça m'a coûté
je vous dis pas de conneries je te jure
la palette avec environ 2 fois attends
tu es tout pendant gourmands enfin si
besoin la télé m'a dit quoi on trouvera
toutes les piles
oui bien veut pas jamais il ne veut rien
et vous allez voir dans une demi heure
vous allez voir tout ce que fait
remarquer laurent hénart un camion là
que vous avez une maison qui s'appelle
claude chevalier
c'est un live a acheté 700 lapin ce
matin
c'est comme ça
ah oui là de droite sur le sol at the
world
mais lui mais j'ai vite rendre 500
beaucoup de foie gras c'est un sens
beaucoup de fois grand c'est énorme
voilà celle là ça demain non non non
qu'est ce que je vais en faire don à la
moitié comme ça s'émeut de ce temps
qu'elle nous dise pas qu'un peu
accoler qu'est ce que je vais en faire
de tels conflits tu reçois rien tu
verras bien entendu et comme moi et j'ai
bâti l'été dernier
[Musique]
il ya pas mal de grands moments
d'émotion le gamin alors autant qu leur
monnaie bon ça va tu vois tout ce dont
je suis d'accord ce jeu se joue puis
quelque chose du pool est un peu et puis
c'est vrai qu'ils apparaissent à la
partie finale
destockage tu vois c'est vers le bas que
ça va
[Musique]
je me rends de santé
les bons à vue
on a beaucoup de ça elle apparaît dans
la palette et si tu attaques à la gueule
dans les têtards grande gueule et it
your way
il arrive à ce genre soit qu'une le
matin j'étais foutu sébastien et la
moitié de la planète bombe ailleurs ces
procurations maroc on est parti c'est
bon
regardez
j'allais entrer
et l'achète 60 colis tracteur il a
acheté la palette la voie de fait les
traînards et cuisses de canard maigre il
a acheté tous les canards gras qui sont
l'avant il acheter
la canard les canards et les canettes là
bas on est fils et il m'a fait
la moitié de la palette tous les cartons
mare où il va être temps est bien mais
de quoi s'occuper en ont maintenant
[Musique]
ça a comme on dit c'est ça une bonne
volonté que les deux parties soient
heureuses tant que ça se passe comme ça
c'est que tout va bien aller au boulot
l'opération mains propres est un succès
tous les stocks de noël ont été écoulés
ce n'était pas le cas même à l'arrêt
mais ça va me manquer
[Musique]
m
dublin en irlande
[Musique]
natacha entame sa tournée les fêtes de
fin d'année sont pour elle une période
particulièrement sensible
elle s'est rendue sur place pour
vérifier que les plus grands chefs
cuisiniers de la capitale ses clients
sont satisfaits de ces services
[Applaudissements]
mais elle vient d'apprendre une très
mauvaise nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
le port de dublin est paralysé par une
grève des ferries toutes ces commandes
sont restées bloquées à l'embarquement
en france une catastrophe
à la veille de noël j'ai un gros
problème avec les ferries ils sont en
grève
toutes les livraisons sont en retard les
restaurants me mettre la pression ils
attendent leurs commandes
ils ont très peur que leurs produits
n'arrivent pas
et combien de clients vous attendent
pour la livraison natacha prend toujours
soin de faire importer ses commandes à
la dernière minute c'est sa garantie
pour offrir aux grands chefs de dublin
les produits les plus frais de rungis
une option qu'elle risque aujourd'hui de
payer très cher en attendant elle décide
de quitter dublin pour rendre visite à
un tout nouveau client installé en
pleine campagne à une heure de route de
la capitale irlandaise
elle a rendez vous avec le dernier grand
chef cuisinier à la mode en irlande son
restaurant mon juliette
tiens regarde c'est ce dont je t'ai
parlé elle a pris soin d'emporter avec
elle une cagette de fruits contre saison
les fameux long de noël de la famille
boyer
elle espère convaincre le chef cuisinier
d'inscrire le melon sur la nouvelle
carte de mon juliette
ouais je suis étonné yves sente vraiment
bon
le chef cuisinier ce livre immédiatement
à un petit test
il demande aux pâtissiers d'improviser
un dessert avec ce tout nouveau produit
de rungis
c'est important pour vous un gie ce oui
je ne sais pas comment je ferais sans
natacha pas ce que les produits que je
reçois je ne peux pas les trouver ici
alors ils viennent directement de rungis
tout ce dont j'ai besoin je les trouve
là bas
est ce qu'il y ait une influence entre
les produits de rungis et votre
créativité
bien sûr plus les produits sont bons et
mieux c'est pour ma cuisine quand vous
avez les meilleurs produits vous n'avez
pas besoin d'en rajouter
il suffit de les mettre simplement en
valeur on n'a pas besoin de compliquer
la cuisine quand les légumes sont
excellentes vous restez simple vous vous
contentez de mettre en valeur les
saveurs qui sont déjà là quand les
légumes sont de qualité moyenne vous
êtes obligé de masquer leur goût mais
les produits que je reçois de rage ils
sont tellement excellent je n'ai pas
besoin de tricher
seles quelques minutes plus tard le
nouveau dessert est prêt le test est
concluant
là on sent bien toute la saveur du melon
avec la cuisson le melon est encore plus
sucrés et la saveur ressort encore mieux
[Musique]
le melon des antilles françaises va
faire son entrée sur le menu d'une des
plus grandes tables d'irlande
[Musique]
malgré sa petite victoire natacha est
toujours inquiète
ces produits sont encore bloqués par la
grève des ferries le lendemain matin 8
heures natascha n'a pas fermé l'oeil de
la nuit
elle a été averti à 4 heures du matin
qu'à un seul ferry était arrivé à bon
port avec un peu de chance ces produits
de rungis ont fait le premier voyage et
sont peut-être déjà arrivé dans son
entrepôt
soulagement tout est là
[Musique]
m
natacha est heureuse mais pour se
rassurer elle vérifie tout de suite 1 1
la fraîcheur de ses produits c'est une
crème je n'ai pas encore tous regardé
j'ai un souci de la qualité de leur
enquête ce moment là c'est pas assez
c'est super les ferries elle est
normalement voté la poursuite de la
grève et cela m'aurait posé de graves
problèmes pour réceptionner attend ma
marchandise si ce n'était pas arrivé ce
matin c'était la catastrophe pour mes
clients
maintenant mon équipe doit faire le plus
vite possible pour livrer mes clientes
ils attendent leur livraison pour lancer
le repas de midi il est 9 heures l'heure
des embouteillages dans la banlieue de
dublin
toutes les livraisons doivent être
assurés en un temps record
[Musique]
le challenge du jour c'est de tout
livrer à temps maintenant ça c'est sûr
c'est stressant
tous les chefs attendent ça va être dur
[Musique]
natacha doit faire livrer une vingtaine
de restaurants à 20 heures les
cuisiniers sa patiente
saleh il y en ait encore oui un petit
peu
ça tout va bien la prochaine fois il
faudrait arriver plus tôt quand même je
suis désolé
[Musique]
tu vois bien c'est fini pas vraiment le
prochain livre et c'est le plus gros
client est le plus dur à livrer parce
qu'il est au troisième étage
le dernier grand restaurant a livré est
un des clients les plus importants de
natacha la livraison arrive à temps mais
avec un petit défaut le chef cuisinier
n'est pas satisfait du calibre de
certaines cuisse de volaille
natacha j'ai un problème ce ne sont pas
des cuisses que j'ai commandé
[Musique]
en fait celle que vous vouliez ont
augmenté mais celles ci viennent du même
producteur c'est quand même du label
rouge
mais le problème c'est que ses cuisses
elles sont bien trop grosse quelle est
la taille idéale que vous souhaitez des
cuisses plus petit
enfin je veux dire pas celle de dolly
parton plus mince quoi
pour quoi travaillez-vous avec natacha
mais parce que les craquantes
non sérieusement parce qu'elle me
fournit des super produit qu'on ne peut
pas trouver à dublin
ici il y a une ou deux sociétés qui
peuvent fournir des produits frais de
qualité venant de rungis savez en
irlande on n'a rien juste des pommes de
terre et des oignons est ce que la
qualité et la variété de ses produits
vous permet de mieux exprimer votre art
culinaire
oui en fait aujourd'hui grâce à rungis
on peut avoir accès à tous les produits
c'est pourquoi dublin et il y a juste
cinquante les restaurants ont commencé à
pousser comme des champignons
il ya dix ans il y en avait 20 à dublin
et aujourd'hui il y en a probablement
1200 en quelques années dublin a conquis
le statut de ville gastronomique
européenne les anciens comme les
nouveaux grands chefs font confiance à
natacha grâce à ce nouveau métier
d'acheteur internationale les yeux de
rungis ont de nouvelles ambitions
elle compte exporter prochainement les
meilleurs produits de rungis vers
d'autres grandes tables à barcelone et à
new york
[Musique]
ce matin sur un des carreaux de la marée
l'ambiance est un peu morose
[Musique]
rien ne va plus chez gilles et compagnie
c'est le dernier jour de travail pour
thomas leroy du cabillaud ses clients
les plus fidèles ont pensé à lui ils
viennent le réconforter par des petits
gestes d'amitié
me fascine bonne combine le petit
démarre aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas si j'ai peur des deux parties
tant que c'est immonde
c'est par cas mais malade et r mais ça
va mais manque t c'est peut être que ça
manque
l'image de régis on n'y va plus y avoir
que marc agissent encore un bras de
rungis qui s'emballe des tonnes et des
tonnes de poissons qu'il a brassé
nauphary des centaines de tonnes germain
des milliers de tonnes de poissons qu'il
a brassé et c'est vrai ce que je voulais
pourquoi c'est si dur de partir une
activité chez moi vous pouvez sans son
poisson qui va lui manquer il est
tellement amoureux de son poisson c'est
sûr qu'il est plus mou robots sont les
femmes les familles c'est sa vie c'est
ma vie
vous savez tous les jours avec tact
afone en 42 ans thomas n'a connu que le
cabillaud
ils ne réalisent pas que dans quelques
heures tout ce poisson ne sera qu'un
souvenir
nos existences
[Musique]
encore un un vieux de la vieille ville
c'est le réseau
alors domine sa reprise n d'année à
pouvoir profiter
oui c'est vrai ce qu'elle définit la fin
de votre chose et puis moyen d'en passer
par une nouvelle vie qui commence
voilà c'est dit no 2 8 merci si demain
tu m'as devra prendre le chemin du
retour il a rendu les clés de son
appartement mais n'a toujours pas de
billet pour rentrer c'est pas de
milliers je n'ai rien fait rien il va
perturber la il est perturbé c'est
pouvez vous me dire ça fait des mois toi
moi parce que je savais et puis je n'ai
pas sur le tir billet je n'ai pas fait
pour vous
si si si ça me fait chier pas comment
vous expliquez ça c'est pas du tout pas
le mot bouhdid pour quitter la france
réal départ et je comprends pas que
l'équipe bateau fin de votre indice un
grand bateau tout me quittent le bateau
là
ils accéléraient alors et celle qui
épouse aline varinot tout attendu
l'arrêt un mot mal parce qu'ils ont faim
la pink était la france
pendant ce temps boris cache ses états
d'âme et s'occupe de ses premiers
clients
on semble lui faire confiance
malgré que tous les jeunes soient pas
mordant mais il ya quand même une bonne
graine de jeunes et je pense que ça fera
un bon vendeur parce qu'il allure il a
la carrure il al'allure patron robert
des jeux sur des barres de toit
ces bâtards
ça m'embête un peu quand même
on va passer
parce que c'était un phénomène c'était
un monsieur
je sais que je vais avoir beaucoup de
mal à prendre sa place et
on n'a rien sans rien mais qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on s'attache autant
parce que j'aime bien et sociable je me
suis retrouvé dans le poisson et je suis
très bien c'est pas dans un bureau fermé
au téléphone et tout s'est vraiment là
il faut un contact social
dans quelques semaines avec l'aide de
thomas morris a fait grimper le chiffre
des ventes sa jeunesse attire la
nouvelle génération
toute la chaîne payante elle des
poissonniers tomassi les avait pas avant
et je les ai ici maintenant
on fait 40% en plus depuis que pareil
avec masse parce que j'ai récupéré tous
tes balles et trois en trente cinq ans à
l'appui en tête de stage bas
ancien j'essaie de les accrocher mais
j'aurai plus de 20
la partie n'est pas gagnée pour boris
ils redoutent le départ de thomas et de
la réaction des vieux clients mais
thomas ne supporterait pas que la maison
gilles perdre sa place de leader dans le
cabillaud
alors thomas a pensé à tout
[Musique]
ça va ça va ya ap du sigle
responsabilité
il va garder à l'oeil d'attribuer
normalement oui de quelle manière
en cas de pépin
maurice pourra toujours compter sur le
roi du cabillaud
[Musique]
il est 4h30 sur le marché certains
restaurants sont déjà ouverts ce matin
la marmite affiche complet toute
l'équipe de monsieur gilles a préparé un
pot d'adieu pour le départ à la retraite
de thomas leroy du cabillaud a même
droit son buste
tout le monde cette entreprise a tenu
manifesté le plaisir d avoir failli avec
toi et donc ils ont mais un petit peu de
l'or leur coeur dans un an une enveloppe
qui te permettra de faire un petit
voyage
et ça ça permettra de souvenirs de
nouvelle génération et la régénération
on va me dire bien fort quand même une
dernière fois thomass les
applaudissements sont un peu tristes
mais à rungis
on ne fait rien comme ailleurs pour
faire oublier le poisson à thomas et le
préparer à revenir à une vraie vie de
couple monsieur gilles a commandé les
services d'une drôle de sirène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kit matin avec le départ de thomas à la
retraite le plus grand marché de
produits frais du monde fermé ses portes
24 heures pour noël avant d'affronter un
nouveau challenge celui de remplir
chaque jour
l'assiette de plus de 18 millions de
consommateurs européens
[Musique]
ouais